it's what police are calling a purely
random mass shooting investigators say a
high school senior is responsible for
killing three people and injuring six
more among the injured two police
officers
[Applause]
on May 15th investigators say
18-year-old Beau Wilson randomly fired
at a series of houses and vehicles in
Farmington New Mexico
foreign
[Applause]
I have eyes on the suspect he's walking
South he's wearing all black skinny he's
in front of the Methodist Church walking
Southbound on Dustin among the victims a
98-year-old woman her 73 year old
daughter and a 79 year old woman body
camera video shows Farmington Police
Officers responding to the scene I'm
being told he's got automatic weapon the
first Applause
he just took off White House directly
south of the church
more shots are being fired
sorry stop right there stop right there
make a contact team give me another unit
to Dustin and Apache Dustin and Navajo
right here follow me right up here by
the White House
White House on the Lefty side body cam
video from another officer shows these
same moments from another angle
White House on the left side
what's up as the suspect continues to
fire toward police video shows the
moment responding officer Sergeant
Rachel deshenza is shot and injured
where'd he go
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry
oh yeah okay
where's your tourniquet
we got one hit give me a medic here for
Sarge
where else you hit me I don't know okay
I'm here all right I got you got another
TurnKey on you deshenza and four other
victims were hospitalized but have since
been released separate video shows the
moment officers returned fire and
approached the suspect get back inside
people
that's it
oh God
circus is down six five six four the
teenage gunman was shot and killed
during the incident local news stations
report he was a varsity wrestler and in
years past had told friends he was
hearing voices they also report he lived
on the Block where the shooting occurred
reporting for a long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie